ارسا تاريخيا عالميا مناطق عده من التراث
العالمي ادرجتها يونسكو في قائمه المواقع
المهدده بالخطر وذلك في اجتماعه الاخير في
باريس بهدف في حمايتها والتقليل من
الاضرار التي تحاصرها المنظمه الامميه
تسمى فاطمه الاوكرانيه الواقعه على ساحل
البحر الاسود كموقع لتراث العالمي المهدد
بالخطر اما عربيا فقد جاءت سبا القديمه
في لبنان كاهم المواقع التراثيه العالميه
المهدده بالخطر وتطالب برسكو بالعمل على
البحث عن المساعدات الماليه والتقنيه
لتنفيذ الحمايه اللازمه للمناطق التراثيه
المتازمه
تاريخنا عظيم للمناطق التراثيه العالميه
التي ادرجت تحت الخطر البدايه من مملكه
سبا القديمه في مارب هي احدى اشهر واقوى
الممالك العربيه تاريخيا ويرجع تاريخها
كما هو مذكور في الكثير من كتب التاريخ
العالميه الى القرن الحادي عشر قبل
الميلاد تقريبا ايضا معرض رشيد كرامه وهو
مجمع يضم مجموعه من الابنيه يقع في مدينه
طرابلس اللبنانيه ويعتبر من اقدم المجمعات
المعماريه التي اوقفتها الحرب الاهليه في
لبنان سنه
1965 اما اضع ساعه هي المدينه المليئه
بالاثار والتحف المعماريه التي تهددها
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه وتشمل مواقعها
الاكثر شهره دار الاوبرا والدرج العملاق
ادي الى المرفق
[موسيقى]
ينضم لنا في الاستوديو يا دكتور منذر
الجمحاوي استاذ علوم حفظ التراث الثقافي
في جامعه الشارقه دكتور اسعد صباحك اهلا
بك هناك معالم اثريه
مهدده بالخطر في قائمه اليونسكو متى يتم
ادراج معلم اثري في قائمه المهدد بالخطر
موضوع ادراج مواقع على قائمه
المواقع المهدده بالخطر لها ظروفها
تبعا لطبيعه الخطر اللي تواجهه هذه
المواقع قد تكون
مخاطر محتمله وقد تكون مخاطر مؤكده
الحالتين
لجنه التراث العالمي للمناقشه هذا الموضوع
والنظر في امكانيات الدوله في اخر
التدابير همم على ارض الواقع لحمايه
الممتلك فاذا ما وصلت الى قناعه على انه
الدوله لا تستطيع تدرج الموقع على قائمه
التراث المهدد بالخطر طيب ثور منذر
اوكرانيا لبنان اليمن بلاد مضطربه امنيا
في الوضع الحالي وغير مستقره هل ستعطى
المعالم المهدده بالخطر وفق تصنيف في
اليونسكو اولويه بناء على الوضع القائم في
هذه البلدان التي ذكرناها
بالتاكيد وضع همم موقع على قائمه التراث
المهدد والخطر هو اشاره الى كل الدول
الموقعه على اتفاقيه همم
تراث العالمي على ان هناك خطر محدق في
موقع اتفق الجميع عليه على انه موقع ذات
قيمه عالميه استثنائيه
يعامل على انه موقع تراث مشترك عالمي فاذا
ما اتفقوا على انه مهدد
فهو تصدير الضوء اولا تصدير الضوء على ان
هذا الموقع بحاجه للدعم بحاجه للمساعدهم
الفنيه والماليه وبحاجه الى التعاضد
الجهود
بيسموه كاسيو او كسب التاييد العالمي
اتجاه تسليط الضوء على هذا بالابعاد
المختلفه قد تكون سياسيه وقد تكون فنيه
وقد تكون مالي
[موسيقى]
ادراج مثلا همم مملكه سبا القديمه وكذلك
معرض رشيد كرامي الدولي في لبنان على
قائمه المواقع الاث عالميه المهدده بالخطر
ما الخطوه المقبله بعد هذا التصنيف
الترميم الدعم الفني وحتى المالي ما هي
خطوات اليونيسكو يعني الحقيقه اذا نظرنا
طبيعه القرار اللي بتاخذ به جلسه
استثنائيه على غير العاديه لمركز تراث
العالمي للجنه التراث العالمي عاده هي
تجتمع سنويا في يعني منتصف شهر
جون ولكن المره هذه لجنه استثنائيه همم
ناقشت ملفات خلال ثلاثه اشهر عاده الملف
ياخذ سنوات من ما يسمى ديسكفريشن او تقييم
نظري ثم تقيم عملي من خلال لجان تقوم
بزياره المكان باخذ حوالي ثلاث سنين اذا
هناك نعم هناك خطر يهدد هذه المواقع
وبحاجه السرعه في توجيه اللي همم الراي
العام الدولي اتجاه هذه المواقع لكن لا
توجد لدى اليونسكو
ادوات الزاميه للدول
طيب دكتور
معينه في بلدان معينه وتم على الفور
التحرك الفوري من قبل حكومه الدوله او
قادتها لحفظ هذه المنطقه وهذا المعلم
الماء هل في تجارب سابق صح كثير يعني انا
بحكي من واقع تجوبتي في فتره عشتك مدير
عام للاثار الاردنيه همم ناقشت معنا
باليونسكو قضايا متعلقه في موقع البتراء
وكان لابد من تحرك الفوري للدولي لاتخاذ
تدابير من شانها ان لا نذهب الى وضع
الموقع البتراء العالم المشهور على قائمه
التراث المهدد وبالفعل قامت الدوله باتخاذ
التدابير ومن ثم همم يعني هدات امور همم
لجنه التراث العالم اتجاه هذا الموقع
استاذ علوم حفظ التراثه الثقافي في جامعه
الشارقه شكرا جزيلا دكتور دكتور